non t'es pas prêt
salut il ya du changement sur la chaîne
aujourd'hui ça fait un petit moment que
je n'ai pas posté de vidéos et pour
cause il ya plusieurs choses qui vont
changer sur la chaîne a commencé par
tout ça par le décor ça si un des camps
j'aime bien mais on peut faire beaucoup
mieux et j'ai trouvé quelque chose de
beaucoup plus sympa on va déjà commencer
par changer le lieu allez on y va
donc voilà le nouveau décor ça c'est mon
nouveau studio alors pour l'instant si
tu le regardes bien la déco est assez
spartiate il n'y a pas grand chose c'est
un petit peu léger par contre y avoir de
la nouveauté de la nouvelle rio qui va
se faire au fur et à mesure d'ailleurs
un site à des avis et des conseils à me
donner des choses que je pourrais mettre
en déco qui trouve sympa tu hésites pas
tu me lemay en commentaire tu me dis ce
que tu en penses et puis tous les avis
sont sombres on être écoutés surtout le
tiens donc tu hésites pas que tu m'aimes
qui commentaire c'est un petit avis sur
la déco va falloir rajouter des tables
un peu plus chaudes parce que là pour
l'instant ça reste un peu froid mais bon
voilà tu vois c'est un nouveau lieu j'ai
terminé de le bricoler n'ya pas
longtemps d'ailleurs je me suis éclaté
j'ai fait de la peinture j'ai pensé les
murs j'ai percé j'essayais
je me suis éclatée ça faisait très
longtemps que j'avais pas fait ça donc
ça c'est vraiment le nouveau lieu dans
lequel je vais bosser dans lequel on va
faire toutes les vidéos alors alors tu
verra au fur et à mesure les choses vont
évoluer il ya des choses qui vont se
passer mais c'est vraiment le point
central c'est mon nouveau studio et ses
lacs effectivement on va pouvoir bosser
alors je te ferai visiter tu verras plus
en détail quand ça sera plus avancées il
ya pas mal de choses j'ai un énorme
frigola avec une très grande réserve
pour faire les provisions il ya plein de
choses pratiques j'ai plein de souvenirs
pleins de choses que j'ai partagée avec
toi donc voilà ça c'est le point numéro
un c'est ce que je voulais voir en tout
premier c'est à dire effectivement ce
tout nouveau studio point numéro 2 c'est
le nouveau site mon nouveau blog je sais
pas si tu connaissais délai par monsieur
greu pourrait faire c'est mon site avant
même que vidéo youtube ce que je m'étais
dessus c'était vraiment plus du
lifestyle à un site d'humour d'humour
décalé sur la vie des hommes j'ai décidé
vraiment le changer parce que autant
j'ai adoré faire ça pendant un temps
autant je pense qu'il faut passer à
autre chose et puis j'ai vraiment envie
de partir sur autre chose comme tu as pu
remarquer la chaîne par quand même sur
du high tech je suis un vrai passionné
de high-tech et j'en parle énormément
d'ailleurs je vais en parler toujours
autant avec un format légèrement
différents mais toujours centré sur la
high tech sur ce qui me passionne et
demain s'il ya autre chose qui me
passionne on parlera d'autre chose
toujours est il qu'aujourd'hui je suis
vraiment à fond sur la itech je trouve
ça génial parce que c'est notre vie de
demain tu verras que les choses vont
évoluer une vitesse grand v on le voit
ça se dessine vraiment avec tous les
objets connectés qui deviennent
d'ailleurs tous de plus en plus
connectés tout s'imbrique sont des
systèmes complets et je trouve ça génial
donc on en reparlera plus tard c'est pas
l'objet de cette vidéo tout ça pour dire
que sur mon blog monsieur gros point fr
d'ailleurs je te mets lien d'acheter un
petit coup d'oeil on parle de high tech
on reprend les vidéos qui sont
présentées directement dans la chaîne il
y aura aussi d'autres sujets qui seront
plus approfondie y aura d'autres choses
qu'on pourra retrouver directement aussi
sur sur le blog n'hésite pas à aller
faire un tour pareil et des commentaires
tu peux me mettre ton avis sur des
articles on peut en discuter tous les
avis sont les bienvenus donc ça c'est le
point numéro deux le blog qui fait peau
neuve
point numéro trois c'est un petit peu
donner une nouvelle direction à la
chaîne alors la chaîne monsieur heureux
je sais pas si tu connaissais quand je
les crée en 2015 mais elle était
vraiment là pour reprendre un petit peu
ce que je faisais sur mon blog c'est à
dire à l'époque de l'humour life style
décalé pour les hommes c'était vraiment
le thème de la chaîne d'ailleurs quand
je me suis lancé plus sérieusement sur
youtube fin 2016 c'est vraiment là
dessus que je me suis dirigé parce que
ça me faisait marrer ça fait toujours
mal mais j'ai plus envie de donner sa
direction à la chaîne j'ai vraiment
envie de donner une autre direction je
t'explique ça en quelques mots la
première chose que j'ai envie de faire
avec toi c'est de partager mon quotidien
de partager mon point de vue et de
partager
mes expériences et tout ça autour du
monde de la high tech parce
qu'aujourd'hui c'est ce qui m'intéresse
on a déjà beaucoup parlé sita a suivi un
peu ma chaîne depuis quelques temps tu
as vu que on a beaucoup parlé de la
nintendo switch trône avec le concept
était super sympa on a pas mal aussi
parlé du dernier samsung le galaxy s eu
d'ailleurs on en reparlera dans les
temps à venir et on a aussi parlé de
l'iphone 8 et on en reparlera forcément
quand l'annoncé officielle va être faite
normalement au mois de juin par apple
pour paraît effectivement de ce nouvel
iphone 8 je suis vraiment hyper
intéressés par tous ces sujets des
nouvelles technologies parce que en
réalité notre monde et notre façon de
vivre pour la plupart d'entre nous est
construit autour de ça les objets
connectés les vêtements connectés
l'intelligence artificielle et toutes
ces choses là s'imbriquent pour nous
offrir des outils de plus en plus
connectés et c'est exactement de ça dont
j'ai envie de parler avec toi en ce
moment en tout cas donc on va vraiment
discuté du high tech on va vraiment
regarder différents sujets de
différentes manières regardez ce que ça
nous apporte et tout ça je le faire en
partageant mon quotidien donc c'est un
espèce de mélange entre du blog et de
l'high tech c'est ce que j'appellerais
un blog éditorialisé on va faire ça
ensemble et justement c'est cette
direction là que j'ai vraiment envie de
doublé c'est à dire que je parte en
vacances je te montre un produit high
tech liette et vacances pour améliorer
ton séjour ça peut être du quotidien ça
va être plein de choses différentes il y
aura pas tous les jours la itech restera
pas nécessairement tous les jours un
sujet intéressant ou que je verrai en
tout cas intéressant voilà un petit peu
le principe de la chaîne d'ailleurs
n'hésitent pas à me dire en commentaire
ce que tu en penses est-ce que ça semble
être une bonne idée est ce que tu as
envie de regarder tout ça et si oui bien
sûr ben tu ta bonne et tu me joly pouces
voilà ça c'était le point numéro 3 alors
puisqu'on parle de partager le quotidien
je vais commencer par raconter un petit
peu ce qui s'est passé hier soir on va
lancer une nouvelle chaîne avec mon ami
coco d'ailleurs que tu as déjà pu voir
une vidéo précédente on a fait son
mariage il ya dix jours à peu près je
passe et a pu le voir en mariée avec son
joli noeud pap il était magnifique
et aux coudes à lancer une nouvelle
chaîne qui s'appelle on s'invite alors
on a été tournée la toute première vidéo
hier soir alors je te fais un bruit pas
rapide on s'invite si tu veux le
principe c'est d'aller au corps un peu
stressé l'as roma je sais quoi c'est
quoi le nouveau maire alors c'est quoi
on s'invite alors s'invite
c'est un truc pour pour aller marcher
partout avec des bons produits qui
coûtent très cher on vous met le lien
dans la description pour aller voir pour
s'abonner à la chaîne est comme ça vous
aurait exclu quand la première bille
noire est sérieusement c'est pour
vraiment tester des produits les plus
chers du monde avec deux langues de
gourmet et les gourmets ça va être cool
on l'a testé hier le boeuf le plus cher
au monde le boeuf de kobe c'était
incroyable on va tester le boeuf de kobe
ont attesté de la viande mature et
c'était génial je t'invite d'ailleurs
allé voir la chaîne tu peux déjà
t'abonner pour l'instant il n'y a pas de
contenu pour l'instant il ya absolument
rien sur cette chaîne par contre si tu
ta bonne dès aujourd'hui dès que la
première vidéo arrivera tu seras
premiers informés et crois moi on doit
vraiment faire un truc super sympa ça va
être drôle ça va être décalé ça va être
gourmand ça va être vraiment un contenu
top on s'est vraiment régalé à le faire
et gustativement et on s'est régalé
aussi visuellement parce que on a
vraiment essayé chercher les plus beaux
plans de temps des presque dans le four
sur les braises on a pris des risques on
a four qui nous a presque littéralement
pété à la gueule mais c'était top
il
on a mangé du boeuf de kobé là on va
manger du bagout vague ou comment
t'appelles ça what you do what you say
de la viande naturel sans le jour
170 jours une côtelette c'est comme
quand la vidéo va sortir vous allez en
prendre plein les yeux
[Musique]
drago travail coco est en forme qu il
est prêt à manger toujours prêt tuant
près était bien c'est shine on s'invite
cette chaîne seule crème merde ça va
juste goûter des choses de plus cher au
monde bombe chez moi on va manger les
choses mais c'est cher au monde vrai que
la viande moi ce que je vous mets les
garnitures à roncq qu'elle a bien fait
on veut faire un petit anigo
[Musique]
et ça donc on va le partager avec cette
future chaîne qui s'appelle on s'invite
et tu verras qu'on a aussi prévu d'aller
faire qu'un tournage différent là dessus
on partagera aussi sur ma chaîne
monsieur creux et tu verras franchement
il ya de quoi se marrer merci d'avoir
regardé cette vidéo si tu as vraiment
envie de me suivre envie de découvrir
tout ça envie de partager ça avec moi
abonne toi la chaîne mais moi un petit
commentaire pour me dire ce que tu
penses un peu effectivement de tout ce
que je t'ai annoncé aujourd'hui si tu as
des avis négatifs n'hésite pas à les
mettre aussi un jeu toutes les critiques
sont bonnes à prendre dans la mesure où
servent du monte ses formes est un truc
washita n'diaye ça m'intéresse
globalement pas par contre c'est
effectivement par un point de vue a
donné tu défends ton point de vue de la
même manière que je défende mieux en
vidéo je suis preneur n'hésite pas tu
mets tout en commentaire et on en
discute je te remercie pour avoir des la
vidéo là il est quelque chose comme
17h08 pas si on voit bien il est 17h 28
c'est l'heure d'aller chercher eliott
qui au centre aéré c'est les vacances
alors pour recentrer tout elliott c'est
mon fils il a trois heures et demie on
va le voir pas mal à paraître d'un côté
ou de l'autre
dans les vidéos donc là il est l'heure
d'aller le chercher au centre aéré parce
que c'est bien beau de faire des vidéos
mais bon j'ai quand même david papa et
faut assurer et papa ça se doit d'être à
l'heure
[Musique]